- [Voiceover] Hello and welcome
to multivariable calculus.
So I think I should probably start off
by addressing the elephant
in the living room here.
I am, sadly, not Sal,
but I'm still gonna teach you some math.
My name is Grant.
I'm pretty much a math enthusiast.
I enjoy making animations
of things when applicable,
and boy, is that applicable
when it comes to multivariable calculus.
So, the first thing we gotta get straight
is what is this word multivariable
that separates calculus, as we know it,
from the new topic that
you're about to study?
Well, I could say it's all
about multivariable functions,
that doesn't really answer anything
because what's a multivariable function?
And basically, the kinds of functions
that we're used to dealing with,
in the old world, in the
ordinary calculus world,
will have a single input,
some kind of number
as their input,
and then the output is
just a single number.
And you would call this a
single variable function.
Basically because that guy
there is the single variable.
So then a multivariable function
is something that handles
multiple variables.
So, you know, it's common
to write it as x, y,
it doesn't really matter
what letters to use,
and it could be, you know, x, y, z,
x one, x two, x three,
a whole bunch of things,
but just to get started,
we often think just two variables
and this will output
something that depends on
both of those.
Commonly it will output just a number,
so you might imagine a
number that depends on
x and y in some way,
like, x squared plus y,
but it could also output a vector, right?
So you could also imagine something that's
got multivariable input, f of x, y,
and it outputs something that also has
multiple variables, like,
I mean I'm just making stuff up here,
three x and, you know, two y.
And, this isn't set in stone,
but the convention is to usually think
if there's multiple numbers
that go into the output,
think of it as a vector,
if there's multiple numbers
that go into the input,
just kind of write them,
write them more sideways like this,
and think of them as a point in space.
Because, I mean when you
look at something like this,
and you've got an x and you've got a y,
you could think about those
as two separate numbers.
You know, here's your number line
with the point x on it somewhere,
maybe that's five, maybe that's three,
it doesn't really matter.
And then you've got another number line
and it's y, and you could think of them
as separate entities.
But, it would probably be more accurate
to call it multidimensional calculus,
because, really, instead
of thinking of, you know,
x and y as separate entities,
whenever you see two things like that
you're gonna be thinking
about the x y plane.
And thinking about just a single point.
And you'd think of this as a
function that takes a point
to a number,
or a point to a vector.
And a lot of people, when they start
teaching multivariable calculus,
they just jump into the calculus,
and there's lots of fun things,
partial derivatives, gradients,
good stuff that you'll learn.
But I think first of all,
I want to spend a couple videos
just talking about the different ways
we visualize the different types
of multivariable functions.
So, as a sneak peak,
I'm just gonna go through a couple of them
really quickly right now,
just so you kind of whet your appetite
and see what I'm getting at,
but the next few videos are
going to go through them
in much, much more detail.
So, first of all, graphs.
When you have multivariable functions,
graphs become three dimensional.
But these only really apply
to functions that have
some kind of two-dimensional input,
which you might think about as living
on this x y plane,
and a single number as their output
and the height of the graph
is gonna correspond with that output.
Like I said, you'll be
able to learn much more
about that in the dedicated video on it,
but these functions also can be visualized
just in two dimensions,
flattening things out.
Where we visualize the entire input space
in associated color, with each point.
So this is the kind of
thing where you, you know,
you have some function
that's got a two-dimensional input,
that would be f of x, y,
and what we're looking
at is the x y plane,
all of the input space,
and this output's just some number,
you know, maybe it's like x squared,
this particular one is an x squared,
but, you know that,
and maybe some complicated thing,
and the color tells you roughly the size
of that output, and the lines here,
called contour lines,
tell you which inputs all
share a constant output value.
And again, I'll go into
much more detail there.
These are really nice,
much more convenient
than three-dimensional graphs,
to just sketch out.
Moving right along,
I'm also gonna talk about surfaces
in three-dimensional space.
They look like graphs,
but they actually deal with
a much different animal,
that you could think of it
as mapping two dimensions,
and I like to sort of spoosh it about.
And we've got kind of a
two-dimensional input,
that somehow moves into three dimensions,
and you're just looking at what the output
of that looks like,
not really caring about how it gets there.
These are called parametric surfaces.
Another fun one is a vector field,
where every input point is associated
with some kind of vector,
which is the output of the function there.
So this would be a function
with a two-dimensional input
and a two-dimensional output
'cause each of these are
two-dimensional vectors.
And the fun part with these guys
is that you can just kind of,
imagine a fluid flowing,
so here's a bunch of droplets, like water,
and they kind of flow along that.
And that actually turns
out to give insight
about the underlying function.
It's one of those beautiful aspects
of multivariable calc.
And we'll get lots of exposure to that.
Again, I'm just sort of zipping through
to whet your appetite.
Don't worry if this doesn't
make sense immediately.
And one of my all-time
favorite ways to think about
multivariable functions is
to just take the input space,
in this case, this is gonna
be a function that inputs
points in two-dimensional space,
and watch them move to their output,
so, this is gonna be a
function that also outputs
in two dimensions.
And I'm just gonna
watch every single point
move over to where it's supposed to go.
These can be kind of
complicated to look at,
or to think about at first,
but as you gain a little bit of thought
and exposure to them,
they're actually very nice,
and it provides a beautiful connection
with linear algebra.
A lot of you out there,
if you're studying multivariable calculus,
you either are about to
study linear algebra,
or you just have, or maybe
you're doing it concurrently,
but understanding functions
as transformations
is gonna be a great way
to connect those two.
So with that,
I'll stop jabbering through
these topics really quickly
and in the next few videos
I'll actually go through them in detail
and hopefully you can get a good feel
for what multivariable functions
can actually feel like.